[Musique]
je plane sur hyrule je tourne comme un
vautour comme un buzz sur youtube j'ai
escaladé tour on n'a pas donné de voix
je communique quand sous titré mais des
fois ferries onomatopées je suis en
forme j'ai dormi longtemps je reviens du
passé j'ai des âmes solides un coût
mr délicate je suis un cordon bleu je
suis une comme un chef des plats
douteuses pour masterchef je peux mais
quoi un lézard ou deux parfois je sauve
l'humanité parfois je paye des
champignons de mon équipe est dur timko
rouge fait des tas de messages sur ma
tablette sheika ma petite tenue saura
pas faire kiffer zelda que des bombes à
l'infini rondes et carrées à la fois je
peux pas prendre l'avion impossible pour
moi de passer à la douane blessés
ça rend fou on va finir par l'interné
mais moi je regarde j'avoue la soluce
sur internet
or à tonnerre sur le torse contre
ganondorf
j'ai le courage d'affronter la canicule
le blizzard les orages libéré les rues
les forces paratonnerre sur le torse
tribord contre ganondorf
j'ai le courage d'affronter la canicule
le blizzard les orages libéré
je suis frais je suis mignon dans tous
mes opus faux ouais bon last et les
débuts un à deux ou trois pixel près
boitant gens commencent millionnaire
conte ruby je collectionne les chevaux
faut que ton poil soient unis pourraient
dans mon écurie
ouais c'est vrai je suis petit mais faut
pas me 32 ans par avoir le dessus de toi
genre temps parce que tu dis oui beit à
bois sont donc la seconde tu m'a copié
en cause paix mettez une contrefaçon
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi je sais
même pas ce que je fais dix mille objets
dans mon sac je sais même pas ce que
c'est avenches péter des poteries des
vases et puis déjà j'étais la hantise de
tous les potiers du royaume encore corps
qui
j'ai pas la clé j'en ai marre aof -
passe partout si tu peux me faire un
cadeau à tous les surfer mais brière
devant la statue ds j'aurais va en
endurance si j'étais en eps du cas l'air
dans le sanctuaire sacré miyamoto mais
quand je déprime proches ressort
l'ocarina poteau on est plus à personne
qu'il arrête quand je parcours les
donjons oui là il me reste une de midi
et g10 est toute ma position je
m'appelle pas elle tarde pas
damman elles ne connaissent même pas
[Musique]
à
sombré dans le lac qinghai
là
respirer sous l'eau ce faux pas
bah
[Musique]
amigo inc revient bon et j'en peux plus
de toi lâché au bout de ma vie tu me
fatigues
à tonnerre sur le torse contre ganondorf
j'ai eu le courage d'affronter la
canicule le blizzard les orages libéré
hyrule
paratonnerre sur le torse contre canon
d'or
j'ai eu le courage d'affronter la
canicule le blizzard les orages libéré
rue
[Musique]
et
link
j'ai vu tout et combattez efforts ce
courage tu as combattu de temps des
demies pour venir me délivrer
avant tour maintenant de tout donner ce
que tu mérites
[Musique]
c'est à dire un grand merci à justin un
grand merci
oui donc on se marie pas genre on a des
enfants on a un pavillon et un labrador
non d'accord peut-être juste un petit
contact physique
ah oui pardon ah ouais donc je me suis
fait flasher zone quoi elle paraît que
si tu cliques sur le tir on l'a et que
tu ta bonne ça fait un son de zelda et
sérieux la braise un nouveau truc
youtube non mais genre là c'est des gens
il habite depuis leur téléphone ou leur
ordi sur le petit rond et qui s'abonnent
ça fait un son de zelda wii vas-y essaye
au [ __ ] génial pose plus c'est la très
forte
c'est la très bonne foi